let me let me pull the store we actually
we actually have the story from music
today from december elon musk says there
aren't enough people birth rate could
threaten human civilization and i think
what people don't realize
is that the only reason we have the
level of technology we do is due to the
specialties of human career human jobs
so let's go back in time we're all
living in caves human beings it was
possible it was possible for a human
being to have the summation of human
knowledge in their brain it was possible
because we knew so little as time went
on we began to learn more and more and
came to the point where you know way
back when you could be a jack of all
trades master of all because the only
jobs were hunter and gatherer
master of both yeah
so you were you were you were let's say
you were in your 30s so you are
spiritually physically mentally uh at
your peak and you're like i am the best
human there is because we didn't know
much but eventually get to the point
where we discovered uh mining um we used
animal labor eventually one person says
i've dedicated my whole life to learning
how to tame these beasts and some other
guy said i only learned how to grow
these crops all of a sudden now the
summation of human knowledge splits and
it's only due to the fact there are more
people able to support each other the
more people we have the more specialty
jobs there are
i watch this great ted talk guy made a
toaster from scratch i love referencing
this
he could not do it plastic was
impossible for him to make he had to
quote unquote mine it by digging up
waste and then melting it all in all he
made the toaster it worked for about 20
seconds before frying out and he said
it's amazing how this toaster cost 10
bucks at walmart but a single person
struggles to make it
there's a there's a book i think it's by
um
lydia help me if you know it's uh no one
knows how to make a pizza um it isn't
about julie julie yeah well i mean no
one outside of chicago knows how to make
a pizza that's a casserole
how dare you the idea is that all of the
elements of a pizza come from so many
different places that's why we have a
conquest big part of it right i started
thinking about this in terms of to
simplify the whole discussion think
about a meal like uh pod thai
the amount an american pad thai sugars
fats oils the rice noodles the meats if
you're gonna put squid in it how all of
these things come from all over the
world or maybe even chicken tikka masala
to us like you go to the store and
you're like 15 bucks and they hand you
the bowl but all these ingredients come
from regions all around the planet
especially in winter where the chickens
might come from the north the tomatoes
come from the south the more people we
have the more unique things we can
create like spaceships
i think about this a lot when people try
to tell like hippie dippies in la would
always try to tell you about the natural
diet that they're on you know yeah
what's the natural diet whatever it was
they were describing you some
describing a way of eating to you that
no human being who lived in nature could
have ever accomplished and certainly not
in winter right like what well we
evolved only to eat like tempe hail
[Laughter]
well i i think i think the issue is um
i think overpopulation is an issue
mostly in density and i had this
conversation with michael malus because
i you know i i think that you got to get
to the nuance of things often these
arguments don't explore the deeper
issues and i said i think overpopulation
overpopulation is a problem
you've got dead zones in the gulf you've
got garbage patches you've got the
windshield phenomenon bug
populations are in decline and all these
things
seem to be tied to you know pollution to
which michael mouse responded yeah but
it's an issue of density in cities and
i'm like i'll absolutely accept that
because i think that's the root of it
and i'm and i'm willing to say you know
what perhaps the solution is people
shouldn't live so close together in
concrete blocks that smell like sour
milk that's right but it's also
there are so many problems with cities
and in terms of our politics and
pollution and
but there's a bigger issue here the the
better point you're making in my opinion
is that as as more and more humans are
born more and more complexity is added
to humanity and that complexity actually
drives things like innovation
so yes you get a spaceship but you also
get uh uh you also get like super wheat
like al alex barlow barlow is the name
of the guy who invented
norman borlaug norman burlock thank you
norman borlaug you know the reason that
we have more people now
and we can eat unlike what they
predicted in the 70s is because we
innovated because now there was a need
for something that didn't need to exist
before that so yes the more people you
add to the world
the the more complexity is added to the
world the more problems are added to the
world and the more potential solutions
are added to the world for instance
colonized space yes yeah and pestilences
there's a mushroom that'll break down
plastic and turn it into sugar which you
can actually eat it's called
pestiolapsus microspora and if enough
people know about that we can recover
like what boyan slats doing in the
pacific with the garbage patch he's
actually recovering it break it down and
eat it i gotta alloy it with that you
can turn it into chemicals and things
can make one real real quick point um we
did an interview with ben shapiro and
ian really shined in his moment because
ben mentioned in a lecture that these
these uh charts and predictions about
climate change never consider mitigation
factors to which ian enlightened ban on
carbon capture graphene production yeah
an adaptive technology that will
eventually what you can do is you
deposit carbon dioxide onto a palladium
copper alloy and then at at some point
we're going to be withdrawing so much
carbon dioxide out of the atmosphere and
producing graphene this new building
material that we'll actually be
competing with trees and if we don't do
it right and start now and start
organizing we're going to overcompensate
and start starving the trees of carbon
dioxide so it's we're going to imagine
this view of it is more of a global
cooling perspective because people don't
consider the new technology that comes
out that could actually threaten the
inverse which is
graphene is this wonder technology that
ian never shuts up about thank you and
you know i got him a little vile for for
christmas
the year before last but uh uh
production requires carbon capture and
that means we might start mining carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere to make
graphene which is a a it's like a super
material yeah that it can be you you
it's it can be manipulated in many ways
it's like what a superconductor super
capacitor it's a conductor it's like a
touch screen wallpaper you can make it
you can make clothing that's like a
touch screen computer so batteries wires
i mean
it sounds like hell i don't want to wear
that at all it's pure carbon
carbon it's
organic in in 10 years the conversation
on climate change may be totally
inverted to these these graphene
companies are cooling the planet well
we've seen it before because the the
narrative was initially that the planet
was cooling and then it was that the
planet was getting hotter and then it's
just that we have climate change
so it can go in either direction
didn't they tell people to drive their
cars as much as they could back in the
day like in the 70s you know what
they'll say now too the the libs and the
alarmists will say oh the global cooling
thing that was just a brief media
phenomenon no scientific institutes ever
really pushed that i have half a chapter
of my book just devoted to outlining
every major scientific institute that
was pushing this stuff they pushed it
for years and now they've completely
memory hold it because it's inconvenient
so of course it's gonna happen again of
course they're gonna go in the other
conservatives love post-apocalyptic
stories like we love walking dead and i
i i say we because i count myself among
the people who loves things like the
walking dead but the truth is my my
world view informs me that it isn't
possible not only that the zombie aspect
of the zombie apocalypse isn't possible
but the entire idea of the complete
collapse of human civilization
is impossible
because we are humans and we innovate
because if there really was a zombie
apocalypse
i would be the god king of zombie
extermination and i would be looking up
to elon musk who would be killing
trillions of zombies somehow like we we
are a highly highly adaptive species and
when a need presents itself we find ways
to meet that need elon did make a
flamethrower
oh i love it maybe he knows something we
don't about melting zombies i i
discovered that that same flamethrower
is terrific for melting harry's and
gillette razors was that the elon
flamethrower it was yeah
of course jeremy boring was going to use
the boring flamethrower
in his video yeah so i i look you know
what my my view on climate change is i
have no problem when you know the the
establishment or mainstream narrative is
that
we met we're we're burning lots of fuels
it's resulting in a lot of carbon it's
warming the planet i say okay all of
that follows as far as i can tell with
with logic but i think ben is right
about mitigation factors and also if you
want to talk more about the heating up
of the planet it looks like there's
evidence that we're still in an ice age
and that what happened 13 000 years ago
is a comet shattered over north america
peppered the glacial continent caused a
global flood but we're still in the ice
age we just prematurely melted a bunch
of the ice off so we're going to
continue to melt the rest of the ice and
warm so
oh that sounds like that's how you want
to stay
it's interesting because when people
talk about overpopulation it's almost as
if at the societal level what we are in
the west is that unbelievably wealthy
couple with no children and who happen
to be debating whether or not they can
afford one it's it's just an
unbelievable failure of optimism
ultimately um
it's funny i was at a a bar after i
graduated college with my father and he
was going around asking young people are
you optimistic and they would all answer
yes and he'd say do you want to have
children oh no i couldn't have children
i could never have kids you know
and that stuck with me because people
like to conceive of themselves as
optimistic they like to say i have an
imagination but then they're not they're
not interested in investing in the
future that way and not only that but
they will actually because it's okay you
know if you're not married if you're not
in that position yet but they will shame
other people for having children and
being optimistic and wanting to bring
life into the world and that's a very
ugly thing so my question is if you know
elon musk is the one guy on the other
side of this what's the motivation of
people like if if bill gates is wrong if
all of these billionaires are wrong why
do they want less people you know there
was a great comment that charlie kirk
made the other day and everyone made fun
of him for it and it was so smart he
said that tall buildings turned people
into libs and media matters made fun of
him and
he said we need to we need to develop
horizontally more than we develop
vertically and everyone made fun of him
except he's completely right going back
to the tower of babel into the present
there was a line that chesterton
observed he said
when you're when you're in the heights
of a building of a really tall building
people look like insects everything
seems really really small when you're
down in the valleys looking up at great
things when you're on your knees praying
looking up only then can you raise your
eyes to heaven only then can you raise
your eyes to hope but when you're at the
top of that building you just feel like
god and you're going to act like god or
what you think god is i think that's
what happened to gates and to all these
other lunatics who are so anti-human
well and it's funny because the left
will you know the the left has this
hyper fixation on media critique and i
think it's good to critique media but
they'll take the most insignificant
elements of a property and argue that
it's influencing human behaviors in ways
far more profound than i think a
reasonable person would acknowledge but
then when you look at architecture which
surrounds us at all times they be they
act as if it's ridiculous to even
insinuate more beautiful architecture
creates a more beautiful cultural it
results in better attitudes i hear what
you're saying michael but i guess my
question would still be even if they
think they're god why less people i mean
certainly if you were god you'd want
more specifically because they actually
do see people
as an impediment to nature and they see
nature as being supreme so you'll
actually read these people say things
like elon musk is going to go to mars
and he'll just pollute it the way we
polluted the earth with the people who
who cares
he's gonna go mine an asteroid the
beautiful natural pristine asteroid that
the asteroid has zero value if there are
no people observing it how dare you say
that people you're saying that people
are supreme i'm actually saying that god
is supreme uh and that god made people
and yes people are surprised
real quick just because i want to lose
this point have you guys ever seen or
read watchmen watch mine yeah i've seen
it but so uh no no no i don't know i
think was it a movie a long time ago uh
not about 10 years ago but the graphic
novel is considered like the better form
but uh there's there's an element of the
story where
dr manhattan who is the one being with
god like powers but he's like i am not a
god you know i can only see my own past
and present or my own past and future he
leaves earth to go to mars he's tired of
humanity and he makes this big machine
look clock-like
and then there's this young woman he was
previously in a relationship with who
wants to talk to him he brings her to
mars and he says look at mars it it has
existed this way for eons with not a
single human or life
would you say to me that this planet
would somehow be better with a shopping
mall or parking lots
and then
ultimately what it concludes with is he
says to her you continually demand i see
the world your way but you refuse to see
the world my way and so she lets him
using his powers
see her entire life you know basically
from start to finish the way he sees the
world but in that moment he sees her
past and in her past
this woman's mother was almost raped by
a man
and then she went back to him later and
conceived this daughter and dr manhattan
says
seemingly impossible a woman who had
every reason to hate this man chose to
love a man she should have hated and
after all the billions of years and the
energy all coming together the only
thing that exists is you i was wrong
miracles do exist it's you you've
convinced me i'll come back to earth
with you and so
thinking about that line brilliant
writing who who was that helen moore
alan moore who wrote that man that guy's
amazing but i thought about that and i'm
just like humanity is each individual
human is so insanely unique in the
billions of years it took to create one
person that person will never exist
again no matter how similar or you know
they may be to another person
without people
it's iraq that's right well i actually
beg to differ this is something called
the blood falls in antarctica and you'll
want to pull this up uh as the glaciers
have been melting and and fresh water is
pouring into the ocean we're like oh
it's going to create dead zones all of a
sudden this blood red water rivers comes
pouring out of antarctica no one knows
what it is so it turns out it's iron
yeah it's ferrous what it's doing is
it's
uh called it's fertilizing the ocean
it's something called iron fertilization
when you introduce iron iron oxide into
the ocean it grows plankton which then
allows food for fish and then you see a
fish boom so the earth looks like it's
preparing for us a flood a freshwater
flood by fertilizing ahead of time uh
we're not alone here as humans
no but but we're the only thing of
value here
um
we exist in nature of course so we have
a uh we're symbiotic in a sense with
nature but nature was given to us by god
the fish has no concept of the fishes
there's no existential crisis for a fish
uh
all anything that we think about a fish
only we think the fish doesn't think it
but well the fear is that if the ocean
were to flood fresh water will lose our
fish population and starve they'll be
giant and it looks like everybody earth
is protecting us but yeah yeah but that
doesn't change uh jeremy or michael's
perspective i would i would view it sort
of from a more secular perspective you
know you can say we're gifted nature by
god i would look at it like
the uh
various forms of life effectively form a
foundation for what humanity is creating
now does it mean to say that i think
humans are the superior in this context
better than any other form of life just
that we're the most adaptable and
smartest and more prone to survival
which from a secular perspective the
strongest survive and everything else
functions as sort of even from a secular
perspective you'd have to say
we're the only being on the planet that
has a moral code of any kind so in some
sense you could say well we're the most
evil because we violate our moral code
and that's true a lion eating a gazelle
isn't evil it's just a lion so we we
both conceive of the concept of good and
of the concept of evil
do we see
animals pray after they kill prey
pray p-r-a-y or p-r-e-y humans
often uh pray before a meal well they'll
pray before a meal but um it also stems
back to after killing that's right
giving thanks to what they have taken
away uh sort of acknowledging that they
they take to you know
they're receiving something else's life
um
i mean maybe there's a case i haven't
heard of of animals recognizing the you
know the the suffering and the pain of
some other animal that they have claimed
their energy to themselves i just look
at it this way
for for the entirety of life on the
planet
you have this constant battle between
evolution or or you know whatever your
view is if a lion is trying to chase a
gazelle and it's too slow it stars the
gazelle becomes faster so only the
fastest lions make it and that's you
know natural selection but then humans
come along and all of a sudden have a
new ability adaptation through
intelligence through tool making and now
nothing can compete with us
this means that of everything on the
planet
we are the ones able to leave the planet
we are we are in complete control of the
planet we have dominated the planet in
every way and it's not a moral judgment
on the value of life at all it's just a
mathematical equation well it's a great
responsibility too because if we abuse
our stewardship of of the planet and of
all the creatures then that's go i think
intrinsically wrong and that would also
be very bad for us so it entails a lot
of responsibility but to this point here
of really humans are kind of what it's
all about on earth
we don't prosecute the lion when the
lion eats the gazelle it would be absurd
to do that and that's why they're
they're not
open to these sort of moral this
translational order different question
if someone owned a gazelle and a lion
jumped in and ate the gazelle and then
fled would we go after that lion track
it down and kill it
probably if he were going to come back
and eat another one i i don't think so i
i actually think that if someone had a
ranch in you know the savannah and they
had gazelle and a lion broke in ate the
gazelle and left they'd be like
i'd go kill that lion i don't i don't i
don't know
when you're an angry
yeah when you look at ranchers for
example in montana who have a problem
where uh
you know
wolves
you know who've been reintroduced in the
population start eating their livestock
they have to defend their livestock they
they defend their livestock because of
the word live like right the the the
more important life isn't the life of
the stock it's the life of the
stockholder but
that is so they're defending themselves
when you know we we get mad when
westerners go over and kill lions in
africa but like the local tribes are
pretty happy about it because they have
to live with those lions but
so my my question is do we do we hunt
down those wolves or we create do we do
we create preventative measures or do we
seek retribution right i'm not trying to
get vengeance on the wolf right i am
trying to solve the problem right yeah
yeah
well the reason i bring this up is
because in the instance where a human
kills a human we hunt that person to the
ends of the earth that's right to lock
them up or in many circumstances
depending on the severity of the crime
put them to death
i'm not convinced we do that for
to the same degree with animals no i
would kill the last panda bear on earth
to save the most reprehensible human on
earth even though there are seven
billion other humans that's a great
point why because the life of any human
is superior to the life of the entire
species of panda now does that mean that
i don't think we have a moral obligation
to be good stewards of the earth or that
i think we don't have a moral obligation
to look after the panda i'm not
heartless i'm not matt walsh i don't
want to i don't i don't mean the panda
harm but i am saying that you know
dennis prager has been asking this
question for literally for 30 years now
every year he asks
if your pet dog
were drowning
in the same river current where a total
stranger is drowning which one would you
save
and he says 30 years ago
everyone said the stranger and today
the majority of everyone says they're
pet dogs that's a great thing really is
that is that good or is it mental
illness thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you